اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه التغطيه
المباشره عبر شاشه العربيه
للزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وفي احدث
الارقام حتى الان خلف الزلزال في تركيا
مقتل
3,432 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 21 الف شخص
فضلا عن تدمير اكثر من 5000 مبنى وفق
ارقام اداره الكوارث التركيه فانها فرق
الانقاذ التركيه مدعومه بفرق دوليه تواصل
عمليات البحث عن جناء محتملين
وشهدت ايضا تركيا صباح اليوم هزه ارتداديه
جديده بقوه خمس درجات فاصله سته من العشره
وفق المركز الاوروبي لرصد الزلازل وقال
المركز ان الهزه سجلت على عمق كيلومترين
هذه الهزه الجديده هي امتداد ايضا للزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا صباح امس بهذا
السياق كشف نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد ان
تركيا شهدت خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضيه
3121 هزه ارتداديا نائب الرئيس التركي
اوضح ايضا بان الظروف الجويه القاسيه تجعل
مهمه ايصال المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه
صعبه جدا واشار الى ان اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
شخص وصلوا من الدول الاخرى لمساعده سلطات
التركيه نائب الرئيس التركي كشف ايضا بان
المدارس والجامعات تحولت الى مراكز
تم تخصيص اكثر من 4000 شخص من العاملين في
المجال الصحي لرعايه الجرحى ويتم نقل
الجرح الى المشافي الكبيره كما يجب فتح
الطرق المؤديه لهذه المشافي وهناك ايضا
مشافي ميدانيه في المناطق المنكوبه تقدم
خدماتها
لجانا الى وسائل النقل الجوي منها طائرات
الاسعاف والمروحيات التي تعمل في ظروف
جويه قاسيه وتحول مطار اضنه الى مطار
اللوجستي لدعم كافه المناطق وايصال
المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ عبر الجو الى
هاتاي وكهرمان مرعش وغيرها هناك اكثر من
3000 شخص وصلوا من خارج تركيا من اجل
الدعم والمساعده
كما اعلن مسؤول تركي في مجال الطاقه بدء
ضخي النفط عبر خطي انابيب كركوك جيهان
الممتد من العراق الى تركيا اليوم بعد
توقفه بسبب الزلزال القوي والهزات
الارتداديه التي ضربت جنوب شرق تركيا امس
[موسيقى]
تركيا منذ عام 1500 تعرضت لنحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا لكن زلزاله يوم الامس وحسب الكثير
من الخبراء والمراقبين كان الاقوى منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
دعامين
تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات علماء
الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاتيك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 2300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمصرع ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
زلزال بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله اثنين
تسبب بمسرع
894 شخصا
زلزالوفان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله
اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
لقد افادت ايضا وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه
بوفاه الخمسين فلسطينيين في تركيا وسوريا
جراء الزلزال واعلنت ايضا من جهتها وكاله
الاونروا وفاه سته لاجئين فلسطينيين بينهم
طفلان جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب ايضا مخيما
قربه حلب
من عمان ينضم الينا عمار عمار المسؤول
الاقليمي لليونسيف في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال لافريقيا سيد عمار اهلا وسهلا بك ما
هو التقييم اليونسيف ايضا الان الى اثار
هذا الزلزال والدمار الذي خلفه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه بالبدايه بحب
نتقدم من يوسف بتعزيها القلبيه لاسر
الضحايا نتمنى الشفاء العاجل للمصابين
طبعا يعني الا ان الاضرار كتير كبيره
على جميع الاشخاص في في سوريا وكذلك في
تركيا وخاصه على الاضواء الاطفال وتشير
التقييمات الاوليه ان الاضرار التي لحقت
بالمرافق مثل المدارس والمرافق الصحيه
ومرافق المياه وتخزين المياه واسعه النطاق
وهناك العديد من الاشخاص الذين كمان
والاولاد والاطفال الذين تركهم منازعهم
منازلهم خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
والان يقيمون في اماكن مؤقته حيث في
الشوارع او تحت الجسور او في بعض المدارس
وياتي كل هذا بينما الاجواء الجويه
القارصه البروده هناك امطار هناك ثلوج
فبالتالي الوضع الانساني سيء جدا فيما
يتعلق بالاشخاص متضررين من الزلزال لدي
كبر قامه واحصائيات حول الاطفال ربما
الذين تضرروا كانوا ضمن الضحايا المصابين
الذين فقدوا عائلاتهم حتى لا جراء هذا
الزلزال سيد عمار ليس هناك احصائيات دقيقه
لكن اعتقد ان عدد الاطفال المتضررين من
جرحى او الذين للاسف لقوا حتفهم تقدر
بالمئات لم يكن بالالاف لذلك من اهميه
كمان الاشاره الى اهميه طبعا المساعدات
الانسانيه العاجله كما اشرت السابقا
الاشخاص الاطفال هم اكثر عرضه طبعا
في صدمه من حيث الزلزال الهزات الارتداديه
بالاضافه الى ذلك الى الظروف الجويه في
اماكن غير اقامتهم فبالتالي يجب ان يكون
هناك عمل سريع فيما يتعلق بالاحتياجات
الانسانيه لمتطلبات الاهالي والاطفال
وايضا فيما يتعلق النفسيه الى اي مدى
تستطيعون الان سيد عمار ضمن يعني اليونسيف
يعني التعامل مع هذه التداعيات تلبيه
الاحتياجات الاساسيه الان للمتضررين من
الاطفال وكذلك العائلات
والمشردين يعني تامين الغذاء توفير ماوى
لهم كيف تتعاملون مع هذا الواقع المؤلم
طبعا يعني الاحتياجات الانسانيه كتير
كبيره
والجلسه منذ الساعات الاولى كانت موجوده
على الارض لتقييم الاحتياجات الانسانيه
واستطعنا كمان اننا نقوم
بالاستجابه لبعض الاحتياجات الانسانيه
العاجله من ضمنها الامدادات الجراحيه
المتخصصه وغيرها من الملاكم من المواد
الاستهلاكيه الطبيه التي تم توفيرها الى
بعض المستشفيات بالاضافه الى ذلك اعاده
توزيع فرق الصحه والتغذيه المتنقله التي
تدعمها اليونيسف في المناطق الاكثر تضررا
من حيث التغذيه كمان كتير مهم الموضوع
لانه بتعرف الاشخاص الذين تركوا بيوتهم
ليس لهم اي مكان
ممكن يتركوا اغراضهم اكلهم تركوا اموالهم
فبالتالي يجب من حيث التغذيه اليونسف
ستقوم بتوفير حزمه كامله من البسكويت على
الطاقه مع شركائنا كمان هناك تنسيق مع
برنامج التغطيه العالمي بشان توفير
الوجبات الساخنه وكذلك في ايضا هناك فرقه
تتعلق بالتقييم السريع فيما يتعلق بموضوع
المياه الصالحه للشرب تعرف انت سيدي
الكريم فيما يتعلق بالهزل الارضيه ممكن
يصير في تشويقات او في الشبكات نقل المياه
مع وجود الكوليرا في سوريا التي بدا في
شهر سبتمبر 2022 ممكن يكون امام ازمه
انسانيه جديده كمان مستجده ان لم يتم
معالجتها بشكل سريع فهناك تقييم فيما
يتعلق بالمناطق الاكثر تضررا للشبكات
المياه ستقوم بشكل عاجل ايضا بتوفير الوتر
يعني الكميات عبر عبر صهاريج مخصص للمياه
بينما يتم فحص الشبكات امدادات المياه
للتاكد من سلامتها او اذا حاجه الى تاهيل
والصيانه ستقوم اليونسف بدعم مثل هذه
الاعمال بالاضافه الى النشاطات اخرى وتقوم
بها اليونيسف خاصه مع الاطفال مع من
تتواصلون الان سيد عمار ما هي
والهيئات التي يقوم اليونيسيفر الان
بالتواصل معها لتوفير هذه الحزمه من
المساعدات في يعني مجالات مختلفه
مع جميع الافرقه الموجودين نتعامل مع
السلطات مع الاشخاص الموجودين مع السلطات
المحليه مع شركائنا المحليين ايضا من
منظمات الاستجابه
من المنظمات المجتمع المدني فبالتالي يعني
علاقتنا مع الجميع لحتى نستطيع ان نقوم في
اسرع وقت بالوصول الى الاشخاص المتضررين
يعني لانه مثل ما شايف مثل ما بنشوف عبر
الاخبار من حيث الوقائع على الميدان انه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه عاجله فبالتالي
التنسيق على هذا المستويات مستمر لحتى
نتمكن من نقوم بعملنا ونوصل للاشخاص
الاكثر تضررا بسرعه ونستطيع ان نلبي
احتياجاتهم السيد عمار فقط تشير الى هذه
الصور التي وصلتنا الان لوصول فرقه من
الجنود الفرن ربما نعم كما كما وصلتني
المعلومات عن قوات فرنسيه تصل الان الى
تركيا ضمن حزمه المساعدات او الفرق التي
تصل ايضا من فرنسا من ضمن فرقه الدفاع
المدني الفرنسيه
لمساعده الحكومه التركيه
والجهات تاتي العلاقه في اجلاء الضحايا
والعالقين اعود اليك سيد عمار كنت تتحدث
عن جهات داعمه ربما تم التواصل مع علي هذه
المساعدات هل هناك توقيت زمني محدد يمكن
الحديث عنه لوصول هذه المساعدات
العمل مستمر على مدار الساعه انا باكد لك
هذا الموضوع وبعض المساعدات بدات يعني
بالوصول الى الاشخاص المتضررين ومساعدات
اكبر ستكون في طريقها ايضا الى الاشخاص
الذين هم بحاجه في الساعات وعلى الايام
المقبله لنقطه كتير مهمه يعني انه
في عام 2023 وقبل الزلزال يعني كان هناك
15.3 مليون شخص في سوريا بحاجه الى
مساعدات انسانيه بما في ذلك سبع ملايين
طفل وخاصه في مجال الحمايه والتعليم
والمياه والصحه وما الى هنالك وياتي
الزلزال الانديفو فاقم الازمات الانسانيه
التي يعاني منها الاشخاص والاطفال في
سوريا فبالتالي نطلب منا الجميع الاشخاص
القادرين على تقديم المساعده لمنظمه
الانسانيه لمنظمه اليونيسف انه يقوموا
بهذا الواجب خاصه انه اليونسف طلبه سنه
328 مليون دولار لبرامجها الانسانيه في
سوريا
وهناك عجز في من هذا المبلغ من قبل
الالمانيين
فبما ذلك الان مع تفاقم الاحتياجات
الانسانيه بعض الزلزال المربع الذي حصل
فبالتالي هذا هو الواقع وهو هذا اللي عم
بيصير على ارض الميدان لكن نحن ما سلمنا
مستمرين يعني عملنا الانساني فيما يتعلق
بمساعده الاشخاص واهم المنتضررين من
يختلف الامر او التقييم لحجم الدمار
بالنسبه لاثار هذا الزلزال حتى الان بين
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها النظام السوري
والمناطق الاخرى ربما التي فيها الماساه
كما يقول الكثير من المراقبين اكبر واعظم
المناطق التي لا تسيطر عليها قوه النظام
يعني بعتقد ان المقاسات صراحه اي طفل اللي
احنا بنخسره هو خساره للجميع بغض النظر عن
اي منطقه كان عايش فيها وين بينتمي اليها
في مناطق القاطعه النظام او الفئه المناطق
الاخرى لكن بالنسبه لنا الاهم انه نشوف
الموجود من خلال التقييمات انه الاحتياجات
الانسانيه كبيره الاحتياجات الانسانيه
موجوده وخاصه لدى الاطفال ويجب ان يكون
هناك استجابه سريعه
لتلبيتها بغض النظر عن اي مكان موجودين في
في سوريا ما هي الاحتياجات الان التي
تعملون على تقديمها للمتضررين
طبعا احنا في المقام اول عم نتطلع على
موضوع الصحه على موضوع طبعا الصحه النفسيه
والصحه الجسديه فيما يتعلق بالتغذيه فيما
يتعلق بحمايه الاطفال الاطفال الذين
يتفرقوا بسبب ايضا الزلزال اعاده
جمعهم فيما يتعلق بامدادات الجراحيه
العاجله للمستشفيات طبعا لحتى تقوم بعلاج
الاشخاص الجرحى من الزلزال توزيع ايضا
فرقه الصحه والتغطيه المتنقل التي تدعمها
اليوسف في المناطق الاكثر تضررا من حيث
التغذيه ايضا سيتم توفير
كميات مخصصه هي من البسكويت عالي الطاقه
هذه مع شركائنا مع برنامج الاغذيه العائله
العالمي بشان توفير الوجبات الساخنه وكمان
في قطاع التعليم
نقوم بتقمه طبعا بالتقييم النتائج هناك
الاف الاسر التي نزحت التي تقيم في العدد
كبير من المدارس يعني على الاقل شيء
تم استخدامها كموى من من حيث الاهالي ايضا
ننظر الى الاحتياجات الناشئه عن وجود التي
تتطلبها التي يتطلبها هؤلاء النازحين
واطفالهم شكرا جزيلا لك المسؤول الاقليمي
لليونسيف في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا من عمان عمار عمار
الان نذهب الى تركيا ينضم الينا موفد
العربيه من اسطنبول غسان ابو لوز غسان
مرحبا بك
يعني رئيس منظمه الصحه العالميه
غسان تحدث عن حاله من القلق الكبير لدى
المنظمه بشان المناطق التي لم ترد عنها
انباء حول حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الضحايا
والمصابين
ما هي المناطق التي ربما لم تصل اليها او
لم يصل منها هذه المعلومات حتى الان غسل
التركيه تحديدا
نعم خالد بالفعل وهو ما يفسر حاله القلق
الشديد الذي تنتاب السلطات التركيه
وبالتالي اللجوء الى المجتمع الدولي وطلب
المساعده الدوليه من دول العالم حتى
اللحظه وصل مساعدات من اربعه عشره دوله
ومتوقع ان تصل مساعدات ايضا من عشرات
الدول ربما 70 دوله كما تحدثت السلطات
التركيه في الاحاطه الاخيره وما زالت
عمليات المساعدات عمليات الانقاذ والاجلاء
والاخلاء مستمره حتى هذه الساعه هناك جسر
جوي انشاه الجيش التركي للوصول الى تلك
المناطق النائيه ايضا المناطق المنكوبه
خصوصا مركز
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه الجنوبيه تحديدا
هاتاي وكرما مارش ودام اديامان تلك
المناطق الاكثر تضررا وتتركز عمليات
الانقاذ في
المناطق هناك اكثر من 5700 مبنى انهار
بشكل كامل وعمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره
لكن الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه خالد حساس وصعب
جدا بسبب
الهزات الارتداديه المستمره والمخاوف من
استمرار هذه الهزات الارتداديه نائب
الرئيس التركي تحدث عن اكثر من 310 هزه
عشره هزات ارضيه
وقعت او حدثت منذ يوم امس وحتى هذه اللحظه
بعضها وصل الى اربعه وخمس دراجات على
مقياس ريختر وهناك مباني متصدعه متداعيه
نتيجه الزلزال
الكبير او الزلزال الرئيسي الذي ضرب
البلاد يوم امس وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من
هذه الهزات الارتداديه
وانهيارات جديده قد تلحق بالمباني
المتصدعه لذلك تطلب السلطات التركيه من
المدنيين عدم العوده الى المباني حتى وان
كانت متضر بشكل قليل جدا لان ذلك ربما
يشكل خطوره على حياتهم في اي لحظه من
اللحظات في هذه الاثناء تستمر عمليات
الانقاذ وتتواصل عمليات لانقاذ ايضا هناك
صعوبه اخرى يواجهها السلطات اتواجهها
السلطات التركيه وهي حاله الطقس المترديه
والعاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب البلاد وتتعمق
شيئا فشيئا وبالتالي هو تحدي اخر يواجه
السلطات التركيه في هذه العمليات امطار
برد وثلوج درجات الحراره تصل الى ادنى او
الى اقل من الصفر وبالتالي هذا تحدي اخر
يواجه السلطات ايضا يواجه المنكوبين
والمديونين خصوصا في المناطق المنكوبه
لانهم يعني الكثير الالاف من المنكوبين في
العراء تحدثت السلطات التركيه عن 52 الف
تم تامينهم في مراكز ايواء في تلك المناطق
وبالتالي ما زالت عمليات
انقاذ والاجلاء مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
تحاول السلطات فتح طرق بديله
لاسراع او تسريع في عمليات الانقاذ
والاجلاء
المنكوبين ايضا هناك فرق انقاذ محليه ما
زالت تتواصل او ما زالت تتجه الى تلك
المناطق اليوم رصدنا بعض الفرق كانت في
مطار اسطنبول تتجه الى هناك بالامس كان
هناك الالاف من المتطوعين الشباب من
اسطنبول ومن المدن الاخرى يتوجهون الى تلك
المناطق لتقديم المساعدات
السلطات التركيه تتحدث عن عشرين الف من
فرق الانقاذ الحكوميه ايضا هناك قوات
الجيش التركي تعمل في عمليات الانقاذ
والاجلاء وايضا يتم استخدام
المسيرات والطائرات يعني متابعه عمليات
الانقاذ وايضا الاجلاء في خصوصا المناطق
التي يعني في المناطق النائيه وبالتالي
العمليات ما زالت مستمره
العمليات هناك صعوبات كبيره تواجه السلطات
التركيه بالاضافه
بتاثير ربما الطقس الامطار الثلوج العواصف
على هذه العمليات هل هناك عوائق اخرى يتم
الحديث عنها الان
يعني استمرار هذه العمليات ربما
عمليات الانقاذ في المناطق المنكوبه نعم
بالفعل هناك
يعني هناك هناك يعني بعض الطرق تضررت بشكل
كبير وبالتالي هناك تحدي امام السلطات في
ايجاد طرق بديله للوصول الى المناطق
المتضرره ايضا البنيه التحدي التحتيه
تضررت هناك وبالتالي تلجا السلطات الى قطع
الكهرباء والغاز عن تلك المناطق وهذا ما
يزيد من صعوبه الاوضاع والظروف التي
يواجهها المنكوبين في تلك
المناطق خصوصا في هذه الظروف الجويه
السيئه جدا تتحدث عن انقطاع في التيار
الكهربائي وتتحدث عن انقطاع في الغاز
تحسبا لاي حاله طوارئ وتحسبا لاي يعني
هزات ارضيه ارتداديه ممكن ان تقع هناك
يعني حسب السلطات اكثر من 300 اكثر من 300
هزه ابتداديه وبالتالي هو هذا اكبر
المخاوف امام السلطات وحجم الضرر الكبير
الذي ضرب تلك المناطق خالد يعني يشكل تحدي
كبير امام السلطات التركيه التي يعني تطلب
المساعده والمساعده الكبيره من المجتمع
الدولي والدول الاخرى وبالتالي ما زالت
يعني الفرق الانقاذ
يعني فرق القاده والمتطوعين يتوافدون الى
تلك المناطق تم تحويل مطاري ملاطيا واضنه
الى مطار تجمع للمساعدات الانسانيه والدعم
اللوجستي
لتقديمها الى تلك المناطق عبر الطائرات
العسكريه او حتى عبر الطائرات التي تصل من
الدول الاخرى نعم خالد الاتحاد الاوروبي
لا يمكن كما نشاهد في هذا الخبر العاجل
يقول ان هناك 12 فريق انقاذ وصل الان الى
تركيا ربما في المطارات التي ذكرتها غسان
ملاطيا واضنه وانه هناك ايضا 18 فريقا في
الطريق هذه الفرق الى علم يعني تتوجه او
اتصل هل هناك فرق انقاذ ربما تصل المناطق
المتضرره ايضا غسان
يعني حتى اللحظه لم يرد اي شيء رسمي بخصوص
هذا الموضوع لكن كما تعلم وكما تناولت قبل
قليل مع ضيفك ان الوضع في سوريا سيء جدا
وفي الاراضي السوريه سيئه جدا وهي بحاجه
الى مساعدات عاجله ربما يكون هناك تنسيق
ما لوصول هذه فرق لانقاذ الى تلك المناطق
اما هنا بالنسبه للاوضاع في تركيا فهي
تركز على المناطق الاكثر تضررا وهي
المناطق المنكوبه او مركز الزلزال كما
ذكرنا هاتاي وكرمان
هي المناطق الاكثر تضررا وبالتالي ما زالت
عمليات
المساعدات او عمليه فرق الانقاذ تتوافد
الى تلك المنطقه عبر المطارات هناك مطارات
مغلقه مثل مطر غازي عنتاب حتى هذه اللحظه
وبالتالي هناك ايضا تحدي الوصول الى
المطارات القريبه
لتوجه تلك الفرق من مطار اضنه مثلا الى
تلك حتى اضن ايضا يعني من المناطق
المتضرره في هذا الزلزال وبالتالي
العمليات ما زالت مستمره
وعمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره لكن الخوف
كما ذكرنا بان هناك مخاوف من الهزات
الارتداديه
ومن المباني المتصدعه والتي تضررت في هذا
الزلزال ومن الظروف الجويه القاسيه التي
تحيط او تضرب البلاد وبما يؤثر على
المنكوبين
وايضا هناك
مراكز ايواء فتحتها في مدن عديده في عشر
مدن بالمناطق الجنوبيه وبالتالي تم فتح
المدارس وصلاه الرياضه وايضا الخيام لواء
المنكوبين في تلك المناطق وهم بحاجه الى
مساعدات عاجله لمواجهه هذه الظروف التي
يواجهونها الان بسبب الزلزال وهم بحاجه
الى اغذيه بحاجه الى اغطيه بحاجه الى
تدفئه في هذه الظروف الجويه القاسيه التي
يواجهونها خالد الى اي مدى هناك يعني
توفر للمعدات الثقيله المطلوبه الان يعني
ربما
لاجلاء العالقين تحت الانقاض كما نشاهد في
الكثير من الصور هناك الكثير من المباني
تضررت وتهدمت جراء هذا الزلزال غسان
نعم صحيح هناك الالاف من المعدات الثقيله
التي يعني موجوده في المناطق المتضرره
هناك يعني تحديات لوجستيه ربما في وصول
هذه المعدات لكنها تصل بطريقه او باخرى
سواء كان عبر الجسر الجوي او بالطرق
البديله التي يتم فتحها او محاوله فتحها
من قبل الجيش والسلطات التركيه هناك تحرك
واسع باتجاه تلك المناطق وتامين هذه
المعدات لكن حساسيه الامر وصعوبه الامر
خالد هو في يعني المخاوف من الهزات
الارتداديه وبالتالي التعامل بحذر شديد
وكبير جدا مع محاوله انقاذ
الموجودين تحت الانقاض هناك تعامل يجب ان
يكون بحرفيه عاليه ومهنيه عاليه حتى لا
يتم هناك يعني تحرك مفاجئ بالابنيه او
بالطبقات المتراكمه طبقات الاسمنتيه
المتراكمه وبالتالي هذا ياخذ وقت كبير
وهذا يعني يفرض ايضا
كبير امام السلطات سواء كان من خوفه من
حدوث هزات او من حاله الطقس او من الوقت
الذي يمضي على الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الانقاض وهم في صراع يعني مع الزمن ومع
الطقس ومع الظروف المحيطه وحتى مع يعني
الاوضاع الجيولوجيه التي ربما تفاجئ
الفرق لانقاذ الموجوده هناك وبالتالي هم
في صراع مستمر مع الوقت وزمن ومحاوله
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من المتضررين
والعالقين تحت الانقاض شكرا جزيلا لك
العربيه الى اسطنبول
نتابع في هذه التغطيه ونذهب الى سوريا
والاوضاع الماساويه هناك حيث خلف زلزال في
اخر حصيله له مقتله
1621 وفق اخر تحديث حصل عليه مراسل
العربيه صحه السوريه كانت افادت ايضا في
حصيله غير نهائيه بمقتل 789 شخصا في طرطوس
في حلب واللاذقيه ورفي ادلب وحما وقد ناشد
الدفاع المدني السوري بتقديم المساعدات
لانقاذ مئات العائلات السوريه تحت الانقاض
في شمال غرب البلاد جراء الزلزال المدمر
الهلال الاحمر السوري ده الى رفع القيود
المفروضه على سوريا للسماح بوصول
المساعدات لغاته قال رئيس منظمه الهلال
الاحمر السوري خالد حبوباتي ان نتائج
الزلزال الذي شهدته سوريا كارثيه وان هناك
حاجه ماسه لمعدات ثقيله وسيارات اسعاف
واطفاء لتتمكن المنظمه من مواصله عمليات
الانقاذ وازاله الانقاض
قبل ذلك قال رئيس الدفاع المدني ان الوقت
ينفذ لانقاذ مئات العائلات التي لا تزال
محاصره تحت انقاذ المباني المدمره بعد
الزلزال العنيق الذي وقع امس واضاف رائد
صالح ان هناك حاجه عاجله لمساعدات من
المنظمات الدوليه من اجل جهود الانقاذ
التي تبذلها منظمه الدفاع المدني المعروفه
باسم الخوذ البيضاء في شمال غرب سوريا حيث
قتل وجرح المئه
نتابع مع جماعه كاش مراسل العربيه من
القامش لجمعه مرحبا بك ماذا عن عمليات
الانقاذ في المناطق السوريه المتضرره كيف
تجري هذه العمليات الان هل هناك اي
معلومات عن ناجين هل هناك تحديثات ايضا
بالارقام
يعني فرص العثور على ناجين جدد بدات تتضاء
مع مرور يعني اكثر من 30 ساعه لها اولاد
تحت الانقاذ يعانون من ظروف الجوع العطش
الفردي اضافه الى الحلقه كونهم تحت طبقات
يعني اسمنتيه متعدده هذا الشيء سمعناه من
عدد من الجهات المعنيه برفع الانقاض
وانتشال يعني الناجين في حال لو كان هناك
رغم انه من يعني هناك العشرات بل المئات
من العوائل لا تزال عالقه تحت
انقاض المباني في جميع المساحات التي
طالتها تداعيات الزلزال سواء في ادلب او
حمص او اللاذقيه او طرطوس وبالتالي يعني
يفهم مناشدات الجهات المعنيه بضروره ادخال
معدات ثقيله وسيارات
اسعاف واليات لرفع هذه الانقاض بان جميع
الاطراف سوى المعارضه او النظام يعانون من
شح ولربما من ندره يعني هذه المعدات
المطلوبه اضافه الى فرق متخصصه في ازاله
الانقاض والبحث عن عن اناس او مصابين تحت
هذه الانقاض هذا ما تفتقره المعارضه وايضا
يفتقده يعني الجهات المعنيه في النظام
السوري لكن رغم كل ذلك خالد يعني من
احصائياتنا احصائياتنا تؤكد منذ يعني حدوث
الزلزال وحتى الان تم انتشال اكثر من 400
شخص من تحت الارقام تم تحويلهم الى النقاط
الطبيه
والمشافي المشافي التي يعني تعاني وضع
ماساوي مع يعني مرور الوقت وبدء نفاذ
كميات الادويه والمعدات الجراحيه والابر
والادويه المطلوبه لاجراء العمليات
الجراحيه جمعه من خلال معلومات التي وصلت
اليك من المناطق السوريه المتضرره يعني
الى اي مدى يختلف الوضع بين المناطق التي
تسيطر ويسيطر عليها النظام والمناطق
الاخرى يعني من حيث
المساعدات التي تصل من حيث عمليات الانقاذ
توفر المعدلات المعدات المطلوبه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه ايضا من الغذاء من
الماوى تامين العلاج
بين المنطقتين
رغم ان المنطقه المنطقه المنطقتين يعني
تتقاسمان اعداد القتلى
812 ب 806 لمناطق المعارضه اي 1620 قتيل
الا ان مناطق سيطره النظام تبدو
يعني الاقل سوءا لا نقول الافضل نقول
الاقل سوءا في مجال يعني في المجال الطبي
ومجال الاغاثه او حتى البحث عن ناجين بسبب
وجود مطار بدات المساعدات الدوليه تدريجيا
تتدفق لاسيما من العراق من الجزائر من
لبنان من ايران هذه المساعدات والفراق
ربما تساعد بعض الشيء يعني الاجهزه
المعنيه في مناطق النظام وخاصه في
اللاذقيه وطرتوس
واسعه من حلب في
العمل الطبي الدعم الطبي وايضا ازاله
الارقام وانقاذ المصابين تحت هذه الارقام
بينما في وراء المناطق المعارضه الوضع
حقيقه ماساوي لان هناك حصار يعني حصار من
جهه النظام قطع في العلاقات مع جهه
الاكراد ايضا مع تركيا التي كانت تشكل
المنفذ الاساسي عبر معبر باب الهوى باتجاه
هذه المناطق هذا المعبر لم يشد اي حركه في
تقديم الدعم كانت المتحده قالت يعني منذ
حوالي ساعتين بانها يعني مساعداتها
المفترض تدخل من هذه المعبر تواجه مشاكل
روتينيه وتعقيدات للدخول اي ان الله شيئا
من قبل الامم المتحده دخلت في من هذا
المعبر تركيا التي تقدم الدعم عبر اراضيها
هي ايضا تعاني من مشكله وكارثه انسانيه
كبرى ولديها يعني اهتمامات واولويات داخل
مدنها او ولاياتها العشر المنكوبه
وبالتالي يعني فرص الوصول الى مناطق
المعارضه يعني من قبل المانحين الدوليين
او الجهات المساعده والدوله اعلنت عن
رغباتها تقديم المساعدات تبدو ضعيفه نوعا
ما
يعني انت تتاكد الان عدم وصول اي مساعدات
لهذه المناطق والمناطق السوريه الغير
خاضعه لسيطره النظام جمعه هل هناك اي
مؤشرات ربما في
المنطقه التي يجب ان تمر بها هذه
المساعدات تتحدثون ربما عن المعبر الوحيد
معبر باب الهواء هل هناك اي تواجد لاي
جهات منظمات ربما تنتظر الاذن او الضوء
الاخضر بالدخول لهذه المناطق
خالد المشكله اكثر تعقيدا من كون الحصول
على الموافقات من الطرف التركي لان هناك
معبر اخرى ثانويه لكن المعبر الاساسي كما
تفضلت ومعبر باب الهوى المشكله انا طرق
تقطع داخل تركيا المطارات مزدحمه بفرق
الانقاذ وبجيش التركي التي تحاول ان تقدم
يعني الدعم للولايات التركيه العاشر
المتضرره وبالتالي وصول الفرق الامميه او
حتى الدول التي تريد ان تصل الى مناطق
المعارضه عبر الاراضي التركيه ستواجه
بمشاكل الطقس انقطاع الطرق حتى في هناك
طرق بين الولايات تدمرت بالكامل وهذه هي
الطرق التي تصل يعني الى الحدود
السوريه بينما يعني من جهه الطرف السوري
لا يمكن الوصول الى هذه المناطق الا عبر
مطار دمشق الدولي او عبر موانع اللاذقيه
واكلها هذه المنافذ تحت سيطره النظام
ستحتاج الدول المانحه الى تفاهمات مع نظام
او حتى المنظم الدوليه تفاهمات خاصه
لتمرير مساعداتها الى هذه المناطق لذلك
نحن نقول بان بحكم الكارثه في تركيا وبحكم
التعقيدات السياسيه
تبدو هذه المنطقه محاصره وفرص الوصول
اليها من قبل المانحين الدوليين تبدو
ضعيفه للغايه يعني قبل قليل كان معنا ممثل
يونيسيف في منطقه الشرق الاوسط من عمان
السيد عمار عمار تحدث عن
حزمه من المساعدات وصلتهم ربما هم في طور
ايطاليا الى المناطق السوريه
المتضرره وهناك اتصالات تجري ايضا مع
العديد من الجهات والمنظمات الداعمه
والمانحه ايضا لهذه المساعدات يعني في مثل
هذه الحالات يعني كيف يمكن ان تصل هذه
المساعدات يعني ربما اتصل هذه المساعدات
بشكل اسهل المناطق السوريه الخاضعه للنظام
لكن في المناطق الاخرى
غير الخاضعه كيف يمكن تصل وفق اي اليات او
شروط يمكن ان يتم الاتفاق عليها جمعه من
خلال متابعتك ورسلك خالد يعني الناس الناس
يعني بشمال غرب سوريا حتى من تصريحات
المنظمات الدوليه يعني مثلا تقول انه ربما
هناك الاف الاطفال قتلوا في زلازل تركيا
وسوريا فالناس يسالون كيف لا تعرف منظمه
بحجم اليونسبت اذا كان هناك اطفال هناك
ملايين ملايين الاطفال احياء هم ابدى
بالمساعدات هؤلاء خارج بيوتهم منذ ليله
منذ صباح يوم امس وحتى الان الاف النساء
الاف الرجال الاف العجائز كلها او لا يعني
نحن نتحدث عن سبعه مليون متضرر يعني
تستطيع المنظمات الدوليه عبر قرارات دوليه
عبر تنسيق خاص من ايجاد اليات بديله من
الطرق البريه او حتى الموانئ يمكنها ان
يعني تقوم بمد جسر جوي باتجاه يعني باتجاه
المناطق المتضرره لاسيما لانه جميع يعني
الدول يعني يعني تفهم هذه الازمه
الانسانيه ويمكن ان يعني تتجاوز قليل
الخلافاتها السياسيه حتى مع النظام السوري
ريثما تستطيع يعني تقديم يعني الدعم
الممكن للمتضررين وفي مناطق النظام او في
مناطق المعارضه لانهم في النهايه جميعهم
سوريين واليوم الان والان الناس فعلا في
سوريا يعني تقفز خلف يعني
انتماءاتها كونهم موالات او معارضه او على
الحياه الناس يردون يعني تدخل دولي سريع
لمواجهه هذه الكارثه غير المسبوخه في
تاريخ سوريا
ابق معي انا اريد فقط ان اشيره واعلق على
هذه الصور التي نشاهدها الان احد المناطق
في تركيا المتضرره جراء الزلزال نشاهد
الان فرق الانقاذ حسب ما نشاهده ايضا في
هذه الصوره اكثر من جهه ربما تساهم في هذه
العمليات عمليات الانقاذ والانت للعالقين
وربما كذلك الضحايا والمصاحب والمصابين من
احد المباني التي دمرت كما نشاهد ربما
سويت بالارض يعني تستمر جهود القائد
عمليات الانتشال ربما نشاهد الان الصور
يعني انقاذ
حسب المعلومات التي وصلتني ولا تاكيد الان
يتم انقاذ طفل الان ربما او انتشالها من
هذا المكان الذي نراه الان تحديدا
وسنتابع معكم من خلال هذه الصور التي
تردنا وايضا خلال متابعتنا وتغطيتنا عبر
شاشه العربيه لكل
التداعيات والتطورات وايضا جهود الانقاذ
المستمره على قدم كل الفرق انقاذ ربما
التي نشاهدها الان في تركيا تحديدا التي
تصل اليها
المساعدات يعني تسابق الزمن للوصول الى
اناجين من انقاض المباني المدمره الصور
مختلفه تماما في المناطق السوريه التي
تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال من خلال يعني
الكثير من الصور والفيديوهات التي تنتشر
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حجم الكارثه
اكبر الماسه كذلك اعمق في ظل يعني وجود
الكثير من التحديات والعوائق امام هذه
العمليات والمناطق المنكوبه خاصه
يعني اكثر من من
تم استضافتهم من المسؤولين من الجهات
المانحه او الجهات التي تساهم الان في هذه
العمليات الانقاذ بانه
المساعدات الصفريه الان التي تصل الى هذه
المناطق السوريه المنكوبه يتم الاعتمادات
على مساعدات فوريه شخصيه فرديه
المبالغ البسيطه ربما حملات من خلال
اللينكات ايضا او روابط يعني تنتشر بين
وخاصه في المناطق الغير خاضعه لسيطره
النظام
المئات من العوائل هم من يقومون بهذه
العمليات في ظل عايز ربما حسب الكثير من
المعلومات في من فرق الانقاذ ايضا
الموجوده هنا تحدث عن فرقه الخواد البيضاء
ربما الدفاع المدني في
المعارضه في في سوريا التي تقوم بجهود
كبيره الان وتسابق الزمن ايضا للوصول الى
ناجين وانتشار الضحايا والمصابين من
المباني المدمره جمعه عكاش مازال معي
طيب نتابع الان كلمه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب
واثر على منطقه واسعه جدا ودمار واسع جدا
في هذه المنطقه لذلك هذا ليس اكبر زلزال
في تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه بل هي من اكبر
الكوارث العالميه التي حصلت في هذه
المنطقه برمتها كل مؤسسات الدوله وكل
مركباتها ووسائلها ومستلزمتها ومعدتها
تتواجد في الميدان الان وبدات بالعمل
لمدى جهود الانقاذ لها قوه هادمه كبيره
جدا وبالتالي اثرت على عدد كبير جدا من
المواطنين ايضا هناك
تحركات من كل انحاء البلاد الى هذه
المنطقه طبعا هناك
ظروف طقس صعبه جدا وهناك الصعوبات ميدانيه
بسبب
الدمار الذي حصل في هذه المنطقه ولكن
العمليات مستمره الى حد الان هناك خطوره
تسببت بها المباني
التي تاثرت من هذه
الزلازل ولكن رغم كل الشروط الصعبه
والظروف الصعبه نستخدم كل امكانيات الدوله
نقوم بمساعده
واعمال البحث والانقاذ
المواطنين العالقين تحت الانقاذ
قل
العاملين في فرق الانقاذ تعمل الان وهناك
ايضا فرق اضافيه
تزداد بالعمل طبعا هذه الفرق تزداد بالرقم
وتذكقه وعامله ايضا للانقاذ
وهناك عدد كبير ايضا من
متضامنين في هذه العمليات طبعا هناك
مساعدات ايضا يتم تقديمها في هذا الصدد من
الطعام وشراب وايضا المساعده الاوليه
والمساعدات الطبيه والبطانيات وايضا
المساعدات الاخرى الى حد الان
تم انشاء اربعين الف مخيم وارسالها الى
هذه المناطق وايضا
عدد كبير من المعدات الطبيه التي تم
ارسالها ايضا الى هناك طبعا هناك دعم
مستمر للاداريه للادارات المحليه وايضا تم
تعيين
مقام وايضا والي عدد كبير من الوالي من
المدونه الاخرى تم ارسالهم الى هذه
المناطق هناك اعمال مستمره بشكل كثيف
لتقديم الدعم الى هذه المنطقه لاداره
الكارثه هناك ولتنسيق العمليات هناك طبعا
كل وزير في يتواجد لتنسيق لتنسيق الجماعي
لعمليات الانقاذ السيد فؤاد اوكتا يتواجد
في مركز افاد وينسق عمليه الانقاذ من هناك
ونحن لدينا وزراء معنيين في كل مدينه ونحن
نتواصل معهم باستمرار من اجل تقديم مساعده
اللازمه من اجل متابعه كل المستجدات لحظه
بلحظه هناك مساعدات طارئه نقوم بتقديمها
واتملك الدعم نقوم بتقديمه وبالتالي اولا
قمنا بتعيين 100 مليار ليره
كمبلغ اولي لتقديم المساعدات اللازمه
كخطوه اولى هناك خطوط
الهواتف الان
الهواتف النقاله الخطوط الهواتف النقاله
تعمل بشكل سليم وايضا تم ارسال
بعض المعدات وبعض المحدات الاضافيه
والمتحركه الى مناطق ولكن الى حد الان
لدينا بعض الصعوبات في
الوصول الى مناطق الامداد والى مناطق
الانهيارات لذلك نحن نطالب بعدم استخدام
الطرق المؤديه الى هذه المناطق قدر
المستطاع وعدم القيام باتصالات هاتفيه من
اجل التقليل من الضغط على الخطوط الهاتفيه
هناك
بعض الطائرات للخطوط الج قمنا بتخصيصها
لنقل المساعدات هناك اكثر من الف سياره
اسعاف تم ارسالها الى هذه المنطقه وهناك
ايضا مروحيه اسعاف تم ارسالها وايضا 5000
موظف وعامل في مجال الصحه تم ارسالهم الى
هذه المنطقه
ولدينا ايضا مشروع اخر العمل على
التبرع بالدم لابقاء مخزون الدم عالي قدر
المستطاع لتقديم المساعدات الطبيه ايضا في
هذا الصدد هناك
فرق البحث والانقاذ يعملون بالاضافه الى
القوات المسلحه التركيه والقوات الامن
وقوات الدرك وايضا القوات الداعمه وقوات
الدفاع المدنيه ايضا يتواجدون هناك تم
زياده ايضا عدد الفرق التي كانت متواجده
في انحاء بلا تم ارسال عدد كبير منها الى
هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
الطائره الطائرات التي تحمل المواد تم
تخصيصها
نقل المساعدات الى هذه المنطقه طبعا القوه
قوات الامن تتواجد بكل عناصرها الان في
المنطقه وقوات الدرك تتواجد هناك ايضا مع
القوات الخاصه كما انها خصصت عدد كبير من
طائراتها لنقل الشحن الى هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى وجود قوات خفر السواحل ايضا
في هذه المنطقه للمساهمه في هذه العمليات
ونعمل الان على التشخيص الدقيق لمدى
انتشار هذا الزلزال في المنطق وبالتالي
خصصنا المسيرات الان للتصوير من الاعلى
ومن خلالها نقوم على تشخيص المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها
[موسيقى]
المباني المنهاره وايضا
المصابين بهذه الان
تعمل كل
البلديات وتقوم كل البلديات بارسال من
انحاء البلاد تقوم البلديات بارسال
معداتها ومركباتها وكل وسيله يمكننا
استخدامها في هذا
التدخلها لهذه
لعمليات البحث تقوم بارسالها دون تمييز
السياسي او تمييز توجهي في السياسه لذلك
نحن نشكر ايضا الجميع على هذه الخطوات
وعلى هذه المبادرات
نحن الان نستطيع ان نقول اننا نستطيع
اتخاذ او اننا
قمنا على استمرار هذه العمليات
العمليات البحث
مع الاسف تظهر مشاهد مؤلمه بسبب استمرار
البحث وهناك بعض
الزياده في عدد الوفيات في
الانقاذ حيث
اننا في نرى
اننا نقوم بارسال ايضا المرض المصابين
والمرضى والجرحى الى مرسين والى اسطنبول
والى المدن الاخرى في هذه
المنطقه نتقدم بتعازينا
شعب التركي ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
للمصابين وللاشجرحى منذ يوم امس كما
تعلمون اننا
اعلنا الحداد وسيتم تنكيس الاعلام حتى
ثاني عشر من شهر
ابريل طبعا الى جانب ذلك نرى ان هناك
الكثير من المسؤوليات التي يتم اتخاذها
الان ونحن نشارك كل المعلومات
والمستجدات بسبب الزلزال وايضا تم تعطيل
المدارس الى شهر فبراير اجبت هذا ايضا تم
تعطيل المدارس الى عشرين الى التاريخ 20
فبراير
في مناطق الزلزال وفي مناطق هذه
الاكارثه وتم التخصيص عدد كبير من المدارس
والمراكز الرياضيه والمراكز الثقافيه
الصحيه والسليمه
للنجينه من هذه
الزلازل
وطبعا يتم التخطيط باستمرار للمئوي
المؤقته يتم العمل على تخصيص بعض الاسئله
الاضافيه مركز الرياضيه ايضا
لهذه
لتدخلها لمساعده الناجين منه هذا
الزلزال وطبعا هناك كما ذكرنا منطقه
انتشار واسعه جدا وبالتالي هناك بعض
المشاكل في الوصول الى حد الان الى بعض
العالقين تحت الانقاض عدد
الوفيات قد وصل الى ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
وتسعه واربعين
المواطن ولدينا
22,168
جريح ومصاب جراء هذا الزلزال ولكن الى
جانب كل هذه
الاخبار التي نقوم بنشرها او الى كل
مساعينا
لنشر الاخبار السابقه ولاخبار الجميع
بالمستجدات الحديثه ولكن هناك لحد الان
نرى اخبار كاذبه
ونحن الان ليس بوسعنا ان نرحق هذا هو ذاك
لاننا سخرنا كل امكانياتنا لتقديم
المساعدات ولعمليات الانقاذ والبحث عن
المواطنين العالقين تحت الانقاض ولكن فيما
بعد سنقوم بملاحقه كل من نشر هذه الاكاذيب
والاخبار المزيفه على موقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او هنا وهناك الان
هناك الكثير من القاده الادولين الذين
اتصلوا وكانوا على التواصل مستمر معي من
اجل الحصول على المستجدات الاخيره بهذه
الكارثه وايضا لتقديم وعروضهم لتقديم
المساعدات في خصوص البحث والانقاذ
للعالقين تحت الانقاذ نحن نقيم كل هذه
المبادرات والاتصالات ونشكر كل من ساهم في
تقديم هذه المساعدات ونشكر الجميع الذين
كل ما بوسعهم من اجل
عمليات الانقاذ والبحث طبعا هناك عدد كبير
ايضا من رجال الاعمال الذين
عليهم ان يتبرعوا
لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه والى
المنظمات الاخرى من اجل استخدامها في
المساعدات ومن اجل تقديمها للمواطنين
المتضررين من هذه ازله طبعا هناك تفاقم في
نسبه
الاضرار التي نراها في هذه المدن المدن
العشره التي تاثرت من الزلازل الان هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه كوارث هي مناطق منكوبه
وتم اعلانها كمناطق من كوبا و سنستمر
بتسريع وتيره البحث والانقاذ وسنستخدم
الماده 119 للدستور ونعلن
حاله الطوارئ في هذه المناطق بسبب هذا
الزلزال وهذه الحاله حاله الطوارئ ستستمر
لمده ثلاثه اشهر
وسيتم اكمالها اكمال هذه الفتره واكمال
القرارات المتعلقه بذلك في المجلس في
البرلمان التركي
نحن نعيش احد اكبر الكوارث العالميه الان
ونسخر كل امكانياتنا وخطوطنا من اجل
عمليات البحث والانقاذ ونتحرك بشكل سريع
ونرى ان هناك
كارثه كبيره وهناك ظروف جويه سيئه جدا
هناك ظروف الطقس صعبه للغايه وبالتالي نحن
لم نتمكن من التسارع في وتيره المساعدات
هذا ونحن على ونحن على درايه في ذلك نحن
نحاول ان نصل الى كل نقطه في المناطق
المتضرره ونعمل على تسهيل كل الطرق
وسنتخلص من هذا الدمائر الشامل الذي حصل
في هذه المناطق الاولويه الان لتسريع
وسيره عمليات جهود الانقاذ وايضا ايصال
المساعدات الى المتضررين بهذا الزلزال
وبعد ذلك سنقوم رفع الانقاض واعاده
الاعمار كخطوه اخيره
اخواني الاعزاء وفي هذه الاثناء
دوله قطر الان تستعد لارسال
عشر الاف حاويه الى تركيا وايضا هناك
مساعي وجهود لتقديم المساعدات الينا وعروض
لتقديم المساعدات الينا طبعا نحن الان
بحاجه الى كرفانات والى حاويات عدد كبير
منها يصل ولكن نحن بالمزيد بحاجه الى
المزيد من ذلك وسنقوم بتخصيصها الى
المواطنين المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
واشكركم شكرا جزيلا على حسن المتابعه
اذا مشاهدي
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام تابعنا واياكم كلمه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بعد
الاجتماع ربما مع الكثير من المسؤولين في
داخل حكومته التركيه والتي والذي تحدث
باساب ايضا عن
الكثير من النقاط والجهود التي تبذل الان
لتقديم المساعده في البحث والانقاذ كذلك
وانتشال
نجينا ربما تحت الانقاذ من اهم ما جاء في
هذه الكلمه للرئيس التركي اعلن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى الى
وان هناك
22,168 من الجرحى والمصابين كما كذلك اعلن
حاله الطوارئ في المناطق المتضرره
والمكروب بالزلزال لمده ثلاثه اشهر ستستمر
حال ايضا جددت الحاجه اليها قال اردوغان
ان هناك سبعين دوله عرضت المساعده في
البحث والقاد بعد الزلزال وكذلك تحدث في
نهايه خطابي ان دوله قطر
كذلك بصدد ارسال عشره الاف حاويه وقال ان
هناك تواصل مع الكثير من المنظمات والدول
والجهات الدوليه المانحه قال بان التحركات
من كافه
القطاعات من كل انحاء البلاد مستمره تجاه
المناطق المنكوبه التركيه
اضاف ايضا بانه تم التخصيص عدد كبير من
المدارس
والمراكز وكذلك الجامعات
كمقرات لاواء المتضررين واللاجئين
والنازحين وكذلك العائلات المشرده وانه تم
تخصيص طائرات لنقل هذه المساعدات وتخسيس
اكثر من خمسه السيارات دولار
لعمليات الانقاذ هناك عمل او خطه كما قال
لفتح فنادق في انطاليا كذلك
للعائلات والملكوبين والمتضررين يقول ايضا
او قال الرئيس التركي يتم العمل على
التشخيص الدقيق لمدى انتشار الزلزال
والمباني
المنهاره
وتم ايضا تخصيص طائرات مسيره تشارك في هذه
العمليات
اضافه الى
تخصيص 54 الف موقع في مناطق الزلزال
تحدث عن الكثير من الصعوبات التي تواجه
هذه الفرق في الوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه
بالاضافه كما ذكر الى الطقس الامطار
والثلوج ايضا حجم الدمار والدمار ايضا
الذي اصاب هذه المناطق اصاب كذلك الطرق
التي توصل الى المناطق المتاثره بهذه
الزلازل والهزات الابتدائيه كانت ايضا
ضمن الاسباب التي اعاقت ربما وصول
هذه الفرق فرق الانقاذ التي تستمر ايضا في
جهودها للوصول اليها
طالبه بعدم استخدام الطرق والممرات من قبل
المواطنين والاتراك وعدم استخدام كذلك
الهواتف النقاله لتيسير وص هذه الفرق ايضا
للمناطق المنكوبه كنا قد اشرنا ايضا الى
وصول فرق دوليه منها فرقه تنتمي الى
الدفاع المدني الفرنسي الى تركيا الان
نتابع معكم التغطيه زميل احمد الهادي معكم
بعد قليل